foreign
[Music]
s usually lead to more questions
the only constant variable is the
unexpected we can't control it
it's only when you look backwards that
you see how it was all connected
let's begin shall we
that's perfect I like to cook it's just
chemistry
you're on the verge of a major
scientific breakthrough this institution
has a reputation based on the
world-class scientists not the theories
of a pretty lab tech we have rules
you're firing me
yeah
just stop you crying it's a sign of the
times
I would like to offer you a job as the
host of our cooking show are you
concussed no you are poised to become a
TV star welcome to the final show
four three welcome viewers this is
supper at six
[Music]
do I need a catchphrase don't overthink
it never understood what that meant I
stand proudly with the overlooked
Workhorse of the kitchen women and baked
potatoes
[Music]
no one has
a platform what you say matters politics
don't belong in the kitchen a man wants
his wife to make him a drink after a
long day at work why do you assume that
his day was longer than hers why don't
you make them drink
[Music]
you are what I treasure most in this
world not because you are pretty not
because you are smart but because you
love me and I love you
think you can't do it and you do it
anyway
your ability to change everything starts
here
children's at the table your mother
needs a moment to herself
[Music]